Why is everything so hard?!
This is a wonderful comedy,
it's about more
than just trying for a family.
At it's heart, it's about
people and life.
Show me your best
manager point.
Wow.
You're ready.
I love that Nikki is banging
her own drum,
but I feel like she's found,
with Jason, that he just
allows her to be herself.
It's a real matter of faking
it until you make it,
in my personal life.
And also for Jason. He's just
trying to be a grownup,
because apparently you've
to be a grownup to have kids.
How'd it go?
Really well.
Yay.
I managed to convince them.
To give you the job?
No, to keep my current one.
So everyone in series two is
kind of having their own
malfunctions of life.
Every character has flaws, but
they're so lovable at the same time.
Listen man, I need a bit of,
uh, relationship advice.
I'm single and I'm at a wedding
with my wife and her boyfriend,
so yeah, I'm definitely
your guy.
Freddy is lost in a world where
he doesn't have the anchor of his wife
and his kids.
Yeah I think he's learning
hard lessons.
I was never here.
This is an illusion. Okay?
Okay.
There is a boy.
You'd think the social worker
is terribly organized, terribly calm.
Of course Penny is chaotic, and crazy, and
mad, and then that's just, was wonderful to play.
Amen.
Namaste.
The doubts that Karen has about
her relationship with Scott
sort of bubble to the
surface in season two.
You've got to take
more responsibility-
Um, I've been babysitting.
It's not even called that
when they're yours.
It's really comforting to
watch other people
making mistakes and you
kind of feel reassured that
everyone makes mistakes.
I think everyone is trying
to slowly figure it all out.
I'm not sure we ever do, really
properly, figure it all out though, so-
I figured it out.
No you haven't.